there is a horrifying headline coming
out of switzerland
switzerland
has
legalized or is in the process of
legalizing
3d printable suicide pods
an australian doctor philip nietzsche
it's
kind of fitting that his name is sounds
like nietzsche you know this very
nihilistic brutal ab thinker he has
announced that 3d printed devices that
are being called euthanasia pods
or a coffin-like device that makes
assisted suicide accessible for nearly
everybody and without medical
intervention you don't even know for
your doctor you need a note from your
doctor to kill yourself
will soon be available in switzerland
nietzsche has said that his purpose in
making these devices
is so that everyone can commit suicide
with little medical assistance
suicide pods
this is if you want to
blame the left for this
the culture of death
in a really creepy form
but i think you can blame the right for
this a little bit too
this is capitalism man
this is free enterprise isn't it
this is just a businessman
pursuing his business and giving
consumers choice
he's probably not going to have very
many repeat customers but he's giving
cons this guy is going to get rich
selling people their death and even if
he doesn't even if he just gives it away
here it's open source you can 3d print
it for free you don't need to pay a
licensing fee
this is just creativity it's creative
destruction it's but definitely
destruction
i bet there are going to be some people
on the right who are okay with this well
it's their choice it's their body their
body their choice there are people on
the right who actually believe that
some people on the right use that
expression ironically to
point out the hypocrisy of liberals who
claim my body my choice
when it comes to abortion but do not
claim my body my choice when it comes to
vaccines
but folks it's it's just a line it's
just a slogan to own the libs we don't
actually believe that we don't i at
least i don't i as a conservative do not
actually believe that you have the right
to do whatever you want with your own
body or to your own body
no we are constrained by the moral order
there is a transcendent moral order and
we are responsible to that we didn't
create our bodies we didn't choose to
come into this world i hope we don't
choose to come out of this world hope we
reject this culture of death from this
lunatic in switzerland or the lunatic in
australia and then the political
lunatics in switzerland
okay we have responsibilities you're not
just allowed to do anything you want
just because you want to we're not just
pure will okay we're also intellect
we're also moral conscience
all right
if this is
something that your political ideology
can look at and not have a problem with
it's probably time to check your
premises
something has probably gone wrong in
your political thinking if you think
this is fine this
represents the literal suicide of the
west the literal suicide of our
civilization that's bad i don't want i
for one don't want that okay and so the
things that are leading our civilization
to commit suicide
whether that is the destruction of our
culture the emptying out of our churches
the breakdown of the bedrock political
institution such as the family and
larger political institutions the
breakdown of loyalty to our own
countries mass migration the decline of
birth rates mass abortion or in this
case literal suicide whatever it is we
got to stop it because i want to live
okay i want to live
here in this world i want to live
eternally in the spiritual world and i
want our culture and our civilization to
live as well and the libs want it to die
and there are some squishes
who don't really seem to have an opinion
one way or the other they just say well
it's choice well it's whatever you want
well it's the free market well it's
capitalism well no man
there's no neutrality when it comes to
life or death pick a side
hey you
hey hold on you don't know don't go
anywhere yet
it's nice to see you i'm glad you came
by this video and watched it if you want
to see more videos you got to subscribe
you got to ring that bell and even
beyond ringing the bell here which you
should do you got to go over to apple
podcasts spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcast it
takes two seconds you pull out your
phone you type in the michael knowles
show subscribe maybe leave a five-star
review i don't know subscribe we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]